let's talk a little bit about um
advocacy
we alluded earlier to you know sort of
some infighting and the vegan movement
and you know there's a lot of sniping
going on and i spent a lot of time
thinking about like how to be an
advocate for the things that i believe
in and things that i care about
and if you take like the plant-based
athlete movement as an example
you'll see a spectrum of different
strategies from the super hardcore
animal rights advocate who is taking no
prisoners
to the very gentle approach matt that i
think you've
adopted and that is kind of in tune with
your constitution like it just feels
very authentic to you if i had to say
i'm
more you know in your kind of side of
that
that spectrum and i tend to think of it
as
as just trying to be a an optimal living
example of the values and the ideals
that i that i care about
but i think it is really important to be
mindful about how
we communicate these values to do it in
a way that it connects and
resonates with you know as many people
as possible so how do you
like robert how do you think about that
it almost sounds cliche but i like the
expression
that i'm in constant pursuit of the best
version of myself
but that's true like that's that's
that's real that really is true
because i got into this because i wanted
to make a difference in the world around
me i wanted to make a difference with
the farm animals
you know that i was around and and later
i wanted to inspire people and i
i i really truly wanted and want to
make a difference and whether that's
because it makes me feel significant or
makes me feel fulfilled or that my
my life has purpose because i'm
significant in the life of somebody else
even someone who just read a book and
said my life changed because of that
that means something to me and i don't
know if that's a selfish thing or an ego
thing
but that's how i conduct
myself whereas in the 20 in my 20s
it was more about you know i'm the new
tiger woods of the vegan bodybuilding
world you know i'm i'm the i'm the
like the best thing that's come to this
movie driven versus mission
yeah and but that was that was also the
time that was i was in my 20s it was it
was
i think we've all gone through some of
these phases where i wanted the magazine
covers i wanted the tv stuff i wanted
the newspapers i wanted the microphone
and and now i realize that there's
there's so many
messengers out there and so elevating
all these other
athletes who are just in many cases
better representatives
as athletes you know they perform better
in their sport they have better results
they
whether they have a smaller audience or
bigger audience but just giving them
an amplified platform to just showcase
you know what they're doing
is something that really means a lot to
me now in my advocacy
i've never been one i've participated in
in protests and stuff but i'm not good
at it this is not my personality
confrontational stuff is
um i know some people i wish i were more
like that you know i think including my
wife i wish i'm just more assertive in
those kind of things but i'm just not
i'm not and i'm much more of what can i
do what's the best use of my time to
create the most change
and that's where writing came from like
i i that's where
that's why i wanted a book like this i
mean it took a lot of
uh manifesting so to speak to get a
hardcover book like this you know to
self-publish books for a decade and
be on this pursuit since i was in third
grade and said someday i'm going to be
an author
um that's a platform for me i think i'm
a better writer than i am a speaker
i'm better at that than i am at at
talking about animal rights even if i
feel it inside
i'm not as great as a communicator as
others who can just articulate their
thoughts and feelings better
watch like those earthling ed videos and
it looks like he just naturally like is
able to just pontificate you know in the
most eloquent way on these issues
yeah and then there's joey carbstrong
and plenty of other people are just
that's like their strength you know and
so what i've tried to use as my
experience i mean
how many people have been a plant-based
athlete for a quarter century and along
that
journey have gained a hundred pounds and
have been able to have all these
different experiences
because one that's one of the arguments
against a plant-based diet oh you'll do
it for a year or two and then you'll
fail or
you there's no longevity in this or show
me someone who's been doing it for 20
years well
hi he he put on all his mass you know
when he was eating animal products now
the frame was already there from a
lifetime of eating animal products
after so many things you know yeah like
shots that get fired over that kind of
thing
and so i figured there's something maybe
unique about that experience and i can
share that
and then with this new book it was an
opportunity to share all those other
stories from people you haven't heard of
you know caitlin cook or or orla walsh
or sharon feikman or jahina malik who's
been vegan since birth and is a
professional bodybuilder on the highest
level the ifbb
pro and she along with her other
siblings like four other siblings
been vegan since birth and be able to
tell those stories like that's
that's that is part of my advocacy is
i'm a storyteller and i
and i like it i i i just embrace that
that whether it's through audio like
this or video and or writing i
that's how i communicate a message just
through stories and i've got my own and
and everyone has their own story to
share
and if i can help other people share
their stories then you know
that's where i feel like i've
contributed to the movement
[Music]
you